comme l'on pouvait s'y attendre
l'application ce top cow vide et n'a
jusqu'à présent pas été particulièrement
efficace l'appli aurait été téléchargé
seulement 2,6 millions de fois depuis
son lancement il y a quatre mois soit
par moins de 4% des français un chiffre
dérisoire si on le compare aux
applications équivalentes chez nos
voisins 16 millions de téléchargements
pour nhs coville 19 au royaume uni 18
millions pour corona web apps en
allemagne 8 3 millions pour rimini en
italie et même plus de 2 4 millions de
téléchargements pour swiss qu'ovide soit
presque autant qu'en france alors que
nos voisins helvètes sont huit fois
moins nombreux cela dit il est difficile
d'accabler les français quand même leur
premier ministre de ses papilles à
l'exercice le 24 septembre jean castex
avait lui-même admis ne pas avoir
téléchargé l'application et ces mêmes
trompés de nom ce lundi au micro de
france info
avez vous téléchargez l'application se
tape que vite sur votre téléphone
non non et non noah chargé je ne l'ait
pas fait le pourquoi mais vous pousser
les français à faire je n'ai pas
téléchargé tecau vide
alors maintenant je vous annonce en
réalité téléco vide indépendamment de ma
propre personne n'a pas eu les effets
escomptés
de toute façon les chiffres de stocks
que vide n'était pas bon même avant ces
révélations
en cause notamment le caractère du
fameux gaulois réfractaires très
certainement ou peut être aussi la
méfiance vis-à-vis d'un gouvernement
très critiqué pour sa gestion de la
crise sanitaire notamment l'épisode des
masques et puis face à une application
lancée par le gouvernement les français
on craint pour leurs données
personnelles des craintes pas totalement
injustifié puisque très vite après son
lancement l'application a été accusé
d'être plus indiscrètes qu'annoncé mais
ne culpabilisons pas même les
populations ayant téléchargé massivement
l'application sont encore loin du compte
selon une étude de l'université
britannique d'oxford
un tel outil devrait être utilisée par
60% de la population pour une efficacité
maximum et même une fois ce seuil
atteint il faut que l'application
remplissent bien
fonctions et c'est là que le bât blesse
car même en admettant que tous les
français et elle est chargée stop
qu'ovide pour qu'un utilisateur ayant
croisé une personne malade soit averti
par l'application encore faut-il que les
deux téléphones étaient allumés au
moment du contact que l'application
était active sur les deux smartphones
tout comme les bluetooth que le
bluetooth et bien détecté l'autre
téléphone que la personne malade est
bien fait un test pcr et que ce test ne
soit pas un faux négatifs et que la
personne malade ce soit bien déclarer
comme telles dans l'application et c'est
donc aussi pour cela que ce top cow vide
a été aussi peu efficaces seulement 472
notification à de potentiels qu'à
contacter au cours de la semaine passée
alors que près de 8000 personnes se sont
déclarées malades via leur smartphone un
maigre bilan qui s'observe également
chez nombre de nos voisins
alors stop vide n'a pas coûté une
fortune à l'état français seulement cent
mille euros par mois un budget mensuel
qui devrait doubler avec la prochaine
mouture de l'application alors sera t
elle efficace cette fois ci est bien
comme dit presque le dicton qui survivra
verra